airports are busier and train platforms
are filling up
after two years of restrictions and
lockdowns canadians are itching to get
out and travel with restrictions on who
can travel in canada lifting infectious
diseases researcher matthew miller says
it's only creating a modest increase in
risk since most people are vaccinated
and many of those who aren't have had
covet 19. maybe there was a false sense
of security before because
even vaccinated people who get infected
can can obviously continue to transmit
and if anything what this might do is
encourage people to be more cautious
currently there are about 7 million
canadians who aren't fully vaccinated
and nearly a million of them reported
contracting covet 19 since the
immunization campaign began to protect
yourself from those who aren't immune to
the virus while traveling infectious
diseases expert michael lipman
recommends going back to the basics
masks for example are still very good
n95 masks are definitely
will protect you better if you you know
wash your hands just in case they may
want to be more careful when they get
into crowded situations libman also
recommends staying up to date with the
covid19 situation in canada as well as
at the place you plan to visit and alter
your plans accordingly you may want to
consult the professional
maybe a travel clinic that kind of thing
just to see
what's going on in the place where
you're planning to travel things are
things are ever changing being
cautiously optimistic is key while
traveling at this point in the pandemic
charming somani global news